former attorney general william barr was
once considered and note the word once
considered a close ally of former
president trump now he says there was no
reasoning with the ex-president over his
false claim that he had won the election
now barr resigned after confirming there
was no widespread fraud in his new book
it's called listen to this title one
damn thing after another he praises his
former boss but he also makes some
damning observations the former
president
has disputed some of the books he calls
them he calls it a fake book
and bill barr joins us at the table he
also calls you a loser and a coward and
lazy but we'll get to that we'll get to
that after we'll get to that in a second
because the title of the book i think is
very appropriate it's one damn thing
after another because you talk about how
you were raised your parents your wife
your three daughters uh even that you
played bagpipes so you'll be happy to
know that we do have a set of bagpipes
here i expect you to play us off later
on in the show
but you start this book bill bar with a
bang it's it's
you've just given an interview where you
said that there was no widespread
nothing to back up the president's
allegations of widespread fraud you get
a message that says he wants to see you
immediately
you go down to the oval office even when
you walk in the room they're telling you
he's back there waiting for you right
what are you thinking as you're walking
out back there knowing that he is
highly highly highly irritated with you
well i thought it was going to be an
unpleasant meeting and it was and
possibly fire me i expected that i told
my assistant when i left the department
you may have to pack up for me because
he frequently tells people to go home
not go back to the office and so i went
back there and he confronted me over my
comments and i told him that it was the
truth uh what i said
and he started raising some of the fraud
claims and i in detail refuted them and
explained why they were not uh had no
merit
and he got madder and madder and then i
said look mr president i know you're
unhappy with me i'm glad to attend to my
resignation and
boom he hit the table said accepted
everyone jumped and
and he did it twice and uh i
left and as i was getting uh pulling out
of the the white house
two of his uh
lawyers came and pounded on the on the
window
government lawyers and and said but the
president doesn't want you to leave he
changed his mind so but it does sound
like a scene out of the apprentice
you're fired and you say that he does
slap the desk
so but but you didn't leave then
why didn't you leave he clearly didn't
want you to stay
you had already had some misgivings you
write in the book that your relationship
had pretty much deteriorated but you
didn't leave then
why not
i didn't leave then because
uh i i wanted to see how this was
playing out and i thought i could you
know continue to look at these claims
and and make sure that uh people
understood
that most of what well what was being
presented simply wasn't true
and on december 14th which was the day
the state certified the vote which in my
mind and in fact really locks in the
election results i didn't think there
was any way it could be turned around at
that point i tendered my resignation do
you think that he really believes he won
this election or do you think that he's
just talking
i i really don't know the answer to that
he acts like he really believes it but
whether he does or not it's also a
convenient uh
you know it's a convenient uh
position for him to take how close were
they to actually seizing the voting
machines
i don't think
they were never close because that would
have required either me and i said no
or or there was this crazy idea of dod
doing it and there's no way dod would
have taken those machines now yesterday
you basically said if former president
trump were the republican candidate for
president that you would vote for him
my question is
why would you vote for someone who you
described as losing his grip he stopped
listening to advisers and became manic
and unreasonable those are your words so
why would he get your vote in 2024
well
in in our election system we have a
binary choice i think we have choice
between two people and unfortunately i i
think the american people deserve a
choice they they like rather than voting
for the lesser of two evils
and but i would view that situation as
the lesser of two evils i'm a republican
i think that
very progressive policies that are being
that seem to have the center of gravity
in the democratic party are something
that have to be resisted and i couldn't
see myself
supporting a democrat
with
i i also when answering that question i
said you know it's hard to look three
years in advance and see what other
information becomes available but right
now
i i realize the uh the
downsides of trump but i
think i under those circumstances i
still would report the i think the pros
outweigh the cons well i would support
the republican candidate now you know he
the problem with trump you know he's
very headstrong and impulsive before the
election he would listen to
me and his other advisors and secretary
of state and eventually he would come
around and things pretty much stayed on
track i think they were with we were
acting within the law uh after the
election he shut that out but even then
you know the lawyers held the line and
you know talked him out of some of the
uh you know crazier steps but i want to
follow up on nate because i think nate's
making a really good point about how you
talk about him in the book you said you
never really wanted to work with him in
the beginning you said he was a
political opportunist he had he had he
was charming and humor he had humor we
know that but he was also crass
bombastic and petty you say after the
election
that he in the final months he only
cared about himself the country and
principal took second place and so i i
it's so interesting to me that you've
written a book john bolton has written a
book stephanie grisham is writing
writing a book has written a book saying
all these negative things about trump
but nobody said this while he was in
office in real time in real time why
didn't you share it with us then don't
you think that people had a right to
know what you were thinking how bad you
thought it was well the thing about
trump is what you see is what you get i
mean his crassness and and those were
the words by the way my business friends
describing him to me but
uh his his
personal failings including his
pettiness are always on display so that
was not a secret
i was content with the administration in
the sense that i agreed with the
administration's policies i thought his
impulsiveness was two-sided it lent a
certain dynamism
to the administration and he could get
things done and push and push and push
it had a bad side too
uh but i didn't think there was anything
to speak up about
even though you write bill he has little
regard for accuracy of statements you
know i i call that being fluid with the
truth some people call it out and out
lying what you seem to see on a regular
basis well as i say on the in the book i
i go back to that statement by i think
selena zito that said that the media
takes some uh
literally literally yeah but not
seriously and his followers take them
not literally but if you work for him
again
no i wouldn't work for him again
you wouldn't work with him again but you
would vote for him again if he was a
party if i was faced with that choice i
i
i hope i'm not faced with that choice
and i don't think at the end of the day
the party will go in that direction the
other criticism about you is that you
seem to act as his own personal attorney
as opposed to the attorney general for
the united states
he acts it or no you you bill barr
you were acting as as donald trump's
personal attorney
specifically they were talking about the
mueller report where you came out and
many people thought it was a preemptive
strike about the report before the press
and the public had to see it that you
were acting on his behalf as opposed to
acting for the country well you know i i
tried to do what i thought was the right
thing to do under the law the the facts
in any criminal case that i was
presented and
and i did that faithfully now on the
mueller report
the problem there was that i had asked
bob mueller
to give me the report so i could make it
public quickly
and there's stuff in the report
that under the law cannot be made public
it's a crime yeah it was redacted and so
he didn't he didn't do that but i i i
said look i don't want a gap between the
time you give it to me and the time i
can make it public and they gave me a
report that had not been redacted and
that i knew it was going to take about
two weeks and the country had to be told
what the bottom line when was the last
time you spoke with donald trump donald
trump the day i resigned december 14th
would you like to have a conversation
with him not particularly it's
but you don't have a conversation you
mostly listen right
william
we appreciate you thank you so much next
time bring your bagpipes one damn thing
after the other is available and on sale
today thank you very much